here we are 35 years after everything
went down in the comments right you know
doing this series and having done season
1 season 2 now and getting the response
you guys got you got 100% on Rotten
Tomatoes for the first season you know
having that kind of pressure added on to
the fact of revisiting these characters
and this story yeah what's it like
season approaching season 2 it's a good
question because yeah the response is I
mean we expected people to like it but
the the critical response was amazing
and the fan and 100% and all that you
know I felt a little nervous kind of
meant in that that was going to be a
factor of being aware of that but the
second we landed it's just been like
turning the page and you know all that's
muted out it's kind of like the natural
you know the baseball player when Robert
Redford is on the mound and everything
goes quiet that's kind of like what you
do and your work so you can't think
about what the applause is it feels like
the first act is done and curtains
closed and we had some claps and it's
good to know that they like what we're
delivering and that there's a second you
know second act and third and hopefully
on and on you know Johnny of it in the
films is kind of seen as being I guess
more of a villain right or more like
anything but in this show you see him on
the flip side sure in a way what's up
did like approach any different than
this guy it's been great for me it's the
same guy as who was in the movie but its
tail telling it through his point of
view I mean oh I've did the karate kid I
I playing a character like Johnny
Lawrence was should we wait for the cops
yeah there they might be coming for me
so
yes so yes so it's nice to have to see
it through Johnny's lens it's very
natural it's a it's kind of a fit of how
I always pictured him with the absentee
parents and he was misguided and has
this you know so you know I haven't I
didn't seem as a villain then and I
don't see him as a hero or an antihero
now I see him just as around human being
that there's a lot of fun to play and
it's great to go to these different
levels with him man right
working with Ralph again after all this
time did you have to ease back into
matter was it kind of like Ralph and I
become friends for the last over 10
years but getting closer closer and I
thought you know it could be interesting
to see what happens we get on the set
together but our first scene was in the
together was in the dojo when he walks
in and I walk on the mat that was our
first on camera Johnny Lawrence and
Daniel Larusso again and it was right
there again it was very naturally as
those characters are living in us and
yeah you know and fun to let him loose
so with regard to possibility of the
women's shoe appearance at some point is
that in the cards is that something
you'd want to see I'd love to see it
definitely Ali the character Ali's a
huge part of Gianni anybody in the
Karate Kid universe and one two and
three are in the Canon of making a
possible appearance at some point so I
could tell you this at this moment I
know that Ali's a huge part of Johnny's
heart as our a lot of people in his life
so we'll see it's back with regard to
the universe as a whole and the
characters original and some of the new
ones that we've seen in the series I is
the one that you relate to or see
parallels with yourself in the most not
a stoner Johnny just in the in this show
yeah
well I think a Bert who's who's the
little guy that at the end of the Kovac
I at the end of the karate kid
tournament in the new tournament he's
got glasses and I tell him you know no
mercy Bert and he's a small little you
know kind of gawky you know awkward kid
so how ironic relates to him when he
started and Bert has a long way to go as
far as growing all the characters though
I you know Xolo who plays Miguel
Miguel's character is a lot like Johnny
fatherless being raised by a mom so
there's a lot of a relationship there
and Robby
Johnny's Johnny's son Robbie there's
that's an awkward painful relationship
because Johnny's trying to reach to him
and Robby wants nothing to do with him
so I think Bert because he's the most
kind of innocent and he's the beginning
of the clay you know with this show is
there any specific element about it
you're really proud of specifically I
just love that they nailed the tone of
it and that it feels like The Karate Kid
it feels like Johnny and Daniel grown up
and it feels like an expansion of this
world in this universe and all the
characters the themes of bullying the
themes of fathers no absentee father's
and mentorship and karate all of that
when the and the music and the tone and
the style I'm just proud of the way they
put it together it's exactly how the
guys pitched it to me when they first
came up to me with the idea of the show
and a little more nervous last season as
this gonna really work and it came
together and nailed it just right this
is a right tone and I'm really happy
with that and I got people who are gonna
look at season two and maybe consider
looking at getting into the shower like
doing the binge as people often do now
with streaming and things of that what
would you say to someone who's thinking
oh maybe them we're checking out about
season two yeah or the show itself
jumping in at any point yeah oh I think
you could jump in at any point but I
think you know start with Episode one of
season one and most people start there
and get sucked right through the end so
yeah it's highly bin jabal highly watch
boys and I think it's somewhat
somewhat catchy and almost addictive in
a way I mean I watched it and I couldn't
wait to get to the next one and I knew
it was coming so there's something magic
in the DNA of the show and it's about so
you